prime ministers have come and gone but
the policies broadly stayed the same for
decades
count out to china with an eye on its
huge lucrative market
today a major shift instead of just
talking about human rights abuses in
china
the uk has done something about them
along with its allies
mr speaker in terms of scale it's the
largest mass detention
of an ethnic or religious group since
the second world war we are sending the
clearest message to the chinese
government
that the international community will
not turn a blind eye
to such serious and systematic
violations of basic human rights
and that we will act in concert to hold
those responsible
to account for the first time four
chinese officials one organization
named shamed and sanctioned for their
part in the treatment of the uyghurs
in a move coordinated with the european
union the u.s and canada
china is accused of wide-scale
repression of the uyghurs in its eastern
province xinjiang
the us has described what's going on
there as genocide
uyga campaigners here welcome today's
moves
but say they don't go far enough every
rights that we have is taken away from
us
and uh even the oils living in exile
we don't feel free we want to see
uh far more actions like
trade sanctions and we don't want to
see this government do any trade deal
with genocidal state today sanctions
come a week after attempts to reset
relations
between china and the us turned into a
slanging match
between officials i'm also hearing deep
concern
about some of the actions your
government is taking
well the u.s does not represent the
world
it only represents the government of the
united states
china's responded angrily today
announcing tit-for-tat sanctions against
european officials
and it's defending its treatment of the
uyghurs this is a
totally wrong decision first
there is no so-called genocide or forced
labor
or master sterilization or other things
we call it the
lies of the century britain and its
allies believe the abuses in xinjiang
too egregious to go unpunished but china
is on the march on the uyghurs on hong
kong
and soon perhaps on taiwan the island it
once reunited with the mainland
apparently determined to carry on
unbowed by external pressure
dominic waghorn sky news